[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my Mandalorian episode 7
video so much stuff happened there was a
bunch of Easter eggs so we'll break it
all down there's also a change to the
schedule again with next week's episode
episode 8 will be the finale so be sure
to subscribe to get everything also
start talking about what's going on with
season 2 when we get to next week they
finally have baby Yoda emerged to sell
so we're doing a giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave your best finale theory on the
video so careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen the episode yet we'll do
top 10 WTF and Easter eggs as we go
along starting with number 10 the title
of the episode the reckoning so it's
mostly a reference to the reckoning for
the mandalorian because Moff Gideon is
finally here Giancarlo Esposito is
character and things are looking very
very bad for the mandalorian and his
crew and baby yoda by the end of the
episode since the events of episode 3
when the mandalorian took off with the
help of the other Mandalorians things
have gotten way worse on navarro we get
more back story on that planet's history
to in its role in the galactic civil war
between the Empire and the rebellion but
grief carga sends a message to the
Mandalorian offering him a new bounty an
opportunity to earn some money and clear
the air between them to some easy cash
to help get rid of the Imperials
obviously it's way more complicated than
he lets on so number 9 welcome back Cara
doon because the Mandalorian doesn't
trust great carga anymore he goes to get
some backup she's back on sore again
where he left her the planet from
episode 4 with a village of krill
farmers that they helped when they did
their Seven Samurai inspired story she's
been keeping herself busy brawling with
the locals mostly for fun because the
xab rack that she winds up defeating
later sort of passes by gives her her
credits for her win she says thanks come
again like it's a regular thing for her
beating up people in the tavern her big
reason for not wanting to jump back into
the fight is there still a bounty out on
her head from the New Republic because
technically she's a deserter but she's a
former rebel shock trooper so she has
crazy good skills that he needs in this
situation the thing that turns her
around on it is when he says they're
going up against X Imperials who she
hates just as much as the Mandalorian
hates droids it just imply that she lost
a lot of her friends during the Civil
War to the Empire
so this is just another opportunity for
her to stick it to them and most of you
probably saw earlier
they kind of explained why the
mandalorian hates droids so much is
because the separatist droid army rolled
into his town where he grew up as a kid
killing his parents and the rest of the
village most of you will recognize that
the Zab rack is the same race as Darth
Maul although his tattoos are nearly as
crazy as Darth Maul's and obviously his
skin is a different shade but that's
just a normals a Brack he's not sis or
anything like that in the tattoos that
they wear aren't just sift at ooze
they're part of their culture so most
SAP rack if not all them have tattoos
like that but the tattoos themselves are
all unique to each different person
speaking of tattoos they also reference
Cara dooms rebel tattoos identifying her
as a rebel shock trooper later in the
episode you might want to cover that up
we're heading into imperial territory so
it's gonna get pretty dicey one of the
funnier things - earlier in the episode
when it's just the two of them is that
you notice baby Yoda poking his head
around while they're talking it reminded
me of that scene during Empire Strikes
Back when Luke Skywalker first lands on
Dagobah
there's also another Dagobah reference
later in the episode that I'll explain
in a second but it's the funny scene
where Luke Skywalker spins around and
Yoda's there and he says it feels like
we're being watched so there are several
times in the episode where baby Yoda
makes it seem like he knows way more
than he's letting on remember he's fifty
years old so a lot of people are kind of
confused as to how intelligent he is
because you would think something that's
50 years old knows way more than an
actual baby because of the way his race
ages it's kind of open to interpretation
he's basically a child by the standards
of Yoda's race but because he's been
around for fifty years he probably knows
more than a typical baby would something
that's really relevant to that - is when
he grabs the flight stick controls and
starts messing around with the ship it
almost like he senses that something
really bad is happening they're heading
into a dangerous situation and he's
actually trying to take them somewhere
else like no don't go I've got a really
bad feeling about what's going to happen
we need to go somewhere else the way
mando and Cara dune play it he's just a
mischievous child somebody needs to
watch him or he's gonna get himself into
trouble but I think the kid was actually
trying to take them somewhere else
knowing that they're heading into a
really bad situation so number eight
welcome back
eggnog who will they go back to recruit
him for help and taking care of baby
Yoda during the trip the
andalorian mentions he thinks that baby
Yoda is a strand cast now that's not
something that's been mentioned in Star
Wars canon before but they're basically
referring to something created in an
artificial gene pool as in something
that you cast create with strands of DNA
I think this is also a reference to the
plans that Moff Gideon has for the kid
using his DNA with dr. Pershing in the
cloning facility at Caminos helped to
create a super army of clones that are
force sensitive and easily controllable
cool mentions the site okay is of Nora
those are also just a new location they
created for the purposes of this episode
where they also do genetic engineering
so there were several references to
genetic engineering in the episode
talking about baby Yoda so I think
that's just giving you an idea for
what's really going on with Moff
Gideon's plan we also get quills full
backstory he says he was sold into
indentured servitude in the empire
during the course of the original
trilogy and paid off his clans debt to
the empire earning his freedom after
which he came here he hated working for
the empire but he was forced to serve
and he did it to help his people the big
WTF we also learned that he found in
reprogrammed IG eleven Taika Waititi
comes back as that character even though
it feels like the biggest twist from his
character is to come during the finale
but he's basically a helper droid now
he's not a hunter anymore as he explains
but he does have really good defense
capabilities they have a big long
montage with a couple funny moments of
him having to reteach him everything so
he became this complete blank slate and
IG 11 becomes a metaphor for baby Yoda
so number 7 the parenting lessons in
baby Yoda foreshadowing when quill is
giving his big speech about rearing IG
11 back talking about how droid aren't
good or evil they're just measures of
the imprints that people put on them so
they're whatever you make them which i
think is a metaphor for the Mandalorian
and baby Yoda baby Yoda could swing evil
or good depending on who raises him and
those values like we could actually
genuinely wind up with a sin of baby
Yoda should the Empire in moth Gideon
get their way and then to reinforce that
idea number 6 something something
something dark side baby Yoda
he totally forced chokes Cara doon when
she in the Mandalorian her arm wrestling
thinking that she's attacking him
mando rushes to tell him no no no she's
a friend please stop and it seems like
baby Yoda doesn't totally understand
what he was doing was wrong he's like oh
I thought you were in danger I was just
trying to help you
who will kind of lets on that he knows
what's going on with baby Yoda even if
he doesn't totally understand the force
he's one of the few people that's
actually talked about Jedi or force
abilities in any kind of way but they
don't directly reference the Jedi or the
Sith but then number five back to
Navarro in the bog wings attack so they
meet with Greek carga and his bounty
hunters one of these is actually a weak
way just like Hondo from the Clone Wars
to that you probably recognize when
Greek carga talks about baby Yoda he
makes a reference to a little bog wing
the bog wings are those giant
raptor like creatures with wings that
attacked them around the campfire just a
little while after this they're native
to Naboo and Dagobah another reference
so calling him a little boggling Dagobah
member of Yoda species just a nice
reference to Yoda himself from the
classic trilogy but just to be clear
even though he's calling him a little
bog wing and that is a Yoda reference
baby Yoda isn't actually a version of
original Yoda he's just a member of
Yoda's species so that's why we call him
baby Yoda we're not calling him the
literal Yoda he's just a member of his
race grief carga does the one thing that
you never do in a situation like this he
says everything's gonna be fine we'll
totally be cool right before the bog
wings attack they carry off two of the
Borg's so press F in the chat to pay
your respects for them but then huge
twist baby Yoda force heals grief carga
paying off that moment from Episode two
when he almost healed mando before he
stopped him
he's using the force to not only get rid
of the poison but close the wounds if
you're not familiar with this particular
force ability it's actually something
from the legends expanded canon so it's
not something that we've seen in the
movies or the TV shows before it doesn't
seem like it drains him quite as much as
it drained him when he was lifting the
mud horn because later in the episode
you seen with his eyes open when they're
running back to the razor crest so he's
not completely passed out for the rest
of the episode but number four the new
Imperials so Greek carga double-crosses
the bounty hunters they go back to town
and we see scout troopers for the first
time on this series on their speeder
bikes nice callback to Return of the
Jedi the one that offers to buy
Mandalorians helmet for 20 credits is
actually played by Adam
who you might remember as this guy from
Iron Man 3 or from Happy Endings he's
done a bunch of character work on TV so
you probably seen him somewhere
almost everything that comes out of
Werner Herzog's mouth in this episode
every sentence he utters is worthy of
its own meme he also gives us way more
backstory on what happened to the
Mandalorians during the great purge that
they keep referring to during the series
why did your people resist the Empire's
expansion their home planet of Mandalore
has been occupied by different
governments throughout history a couple
different times but recently it sounds
like what happened during the original
trilogy is that the Empire officially
wanted to take over and bring them into
the Empire they didn't want to have
anything to do with that and that's what
led the Emperor to call his own version
of order 66 on the Mandalorians we get a
little teaser for Moff Gideon Giancarlo
Esposito 'he's character when he takes
the call please don't think me rude I
got to take this Skype call with my boss
so it kind of makes it seem like he's
been working for him off Gideon this
whole time they give you an idea for how
much sharper he is than Werner Herzog's
character to because he instantly senses
that they're being double-crossed by the
Mandalorian & grebe carga oh really he
brought the child you might want to
double-check on that any kind of
chuckles do himself and then continues
to smile while he watches them gunned
down Werner Herzog's character like he
expected this to happen so number 3 WTF
the Mandalorian kills Werner Herzog's
character it's almost unceremonious but
everything just kind of erupts into
chaos so there's a nice quick action
scene bridging to a much bigger action
scene and big WTF ending to the episode
but as all the Imperial reinforcements
start rolling in number two the scout
troopers capture baby Yoda and seems
like they kill coils character in his
blerg
but remember IG 11 is still fully
functional and waiting back on the razor
crest to swoop in and help them out in
the finale in number one probably one of
the best moments of the episode next to
Darkseid forced choking baby Yoda
Moff Gideon descends from on high in his
regular TIE fighter
revealing himself as the real big bad of
the season so if it wasn't clear he's
been pulling the strings this whole time
he's been the person behind Werner
Herzog in all the efforts to find the
child they have a really cool special
effects scene of them showing you what
it looks like when a regular tie fighter
lands he's wearing a slightly modified
beefed-up version of a tie pilots
uniform but the black
gives you some Darth Vader vibes because
he's wearing a cape which isn't super
common for Imperials so anytime you see
someone dressed in all black armor
wearing a black cape you're meant to
think of Darth Vader and here's a really
important thing too there's a lot of
people that thought this person at the
end of Episode five with the Spurs in
the Cape was Moff Gideon it's not
because listen here when he walks in his
boots don't make any kind of sound he's
not wearing any Spurs or anything like
that so we couldn't have been him we'll
have to find out who that is hopefully
in the finale I don't know why they
would tease that and then not paid off
in the finale but he starts evil guy
monologuing about the true importance of
baby Yoda I've already done a couple
videos about my theory what their big
plan is like I said creating an army of
super clones using his DNA that are
force sensitive and also have longer
lifespans because he lives so long
naturally big reminder that episode 8
will be next Friday like normal this
episode just came a couple days early
because rise of Skywalker is hitting
theaters this weekend congratulations
kylo one one eight four nine you're the
giveaway winner from my last big
Mandalorian video please email me on the
about page of my channel so I can get
your details
everyone click here for my Mandalorian
episode 6 video and click here for my
new baby Yoda video thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I
have spoken
[Music]